I want to talk at length about the
earthquake and the deteriorating
situation in turkey and Syria but just
before we get to there
um I just want to speak about the
Parliamentary committee report into the
appointment of BBC chairman Richard
Sharp because the culture media and
Sport committee which approved his
appointment say that he made significant
errors of judgment by failing to declare
his role in facilitating a loan to Boris
Johnson who was then prime minister
obviously went on to recommend him for
the job of BBC chair do you accept the
committee's findings
well we should be grateful to the
committee this is a senior Committee of
the House of Commons and although I
haven't yet read the report the
headlines are in the public domain I
think I think this is really now a
matter for the BBC
um and also of course the commissioner
for public appointments
um has made clear that they are going to
have a look at it he has recused himself
from the process because I think he
knows Richard Sharp but someone
appropriate will have a look at that and
then we'll see whether there are other
lessons to be learned as you say the
headlines in the public domain Damien
green the acting chair he said the fact
that Richard Sharp didn't declare his
involvement means there are question
marks about the process he says such a
significant air of judgment meant we
were not in full possession of the facts
when we were required to rule on his
suitability for the role of BBC chair I
mean how can people have faith in the
process if that's what he's saying well
I think Damian green is a very senior
member of the House Commons and what he
and his committee says matters but I
think as I say this is really something
which the public appointments
commissioner must look at and we must
wait wait for his judgment and above all
of course it's a matter for the Judgment
of the BBC I mean some other politicians
Lucy Powell of the labor party John
Nicholson and the s p they're saying
that Mr Sharp's position is untenable
well I think as I say we shouldn't rush
to judgment on that we should allow this
process to conclude and then in the end
it will be a matter for the BBC of which
he's the chairman to make a final
decision I mean I guess um it matters
doesn't it because of people's trust in
the appointments process for these big
jobs is there a wider lessons to be
learned here about people who made large
political donations not just to the
conservative party but you know it's
obviously happened with labor in the
past as well about whether they should
be put forward for these big public
appointments well I don't I don't think
the nations of themselves are a feature
which should ban someone from having
such an appointment but the most
important issue is that there should be
full and open transparency and I think
that is at the heart of the questions
that Damien and his committee have
raised so the issue is the transparency
rather than the donation yes I think
that's right and or just finally
um you know I remember you know this
time last year you made it very clear
that you lost faith in Boris Johnson as
prime minister
do you think that this is partly an
example of you know Rishi sunak and the
current cabinet having to clear up the
mess that was left by the previous man
in the job
well I think that's something which
people will have uh different uh views
on what's your idea well I think the key
thing is that what Rishi is doing Rishi
and Jeremy Hunter doing is they are
restoring confidence and the handling by
the government of the British economy
and you can see from the markets and
from the recent economic news that they
are doing a very good job I mean Richard
C Nick also said it was about integrity
as well didn't he restoring faith in the
Integrity of the government yes and I
think the process which we've been
discussing does just that okay now let's
talk um about the earthquake shall we
everyone will see in the absolute
devastation I mean
it's one of those stories for me it's
very difficult to and I'm sure many of
our viewers it's very difficult just to
witness some of the the destruction the
loss of life that's been happening there
you know the official death toll I think
is 28 000 but of course if you speak to
people on the ground it's very clear
that that is an underestimation
I'm afraid that so uh it is Bleak beyond
belief it is the worst uh crisis the
worst earthquake that we Face certainly
since Nepal uh probably since Haiti one
of the heartening things is that lessons
have been learned from what happened in
Haiti when the whole thing was a
disaster reinforced by the fact that
there was no proper coordination in the
International Community piled in and the
response was as a result was not uh
strong and was not right this time
because turkey and the body within
turkey that handles these things Arab is
is much more sophisticated and is really
well organized the International
Community has been able to respond and
Britain was one of the first people to
contact the Turkish government ask what
we could do and to respond to the needs
that the Turkish government set out of
course it's not just Southern turkey
it's also Northern Syria which is
ungoverned space it's much more
difficult to get help and relief there
and and the response to the British
public through the disasters emergency
committee T appeal is unprecedented they
have raised something like 53 million
pounds in 48 hours the extraordinary
generosity of the public is uh amazing
and outstanding and heartening and I
hope that anyone who wants to support
the the disaster's emergency committee
appeal will do so this money will be
incredibly well spent through
International and respected ngos through
the United Nations and it will make a
real difference and the government is
supporting it too through taxpayers
money through matching the first five
million pounds as well so so you know
this is a great effort but it's really
really needed yeah as you say it's
astonishing the amount of money that
people have
taken raised taken from their pockets
and given to the people who say
desperately need it you say that you are
afraid that the death toll will rise do
you think it could double
I think that the figure that the UN
emergency coordinator has given uh
yesterday when he was in the region of
50 000 is the the right figure I fear
that we are going to see
and of course the situation in Turkey
the security situation also seems to be
deteriorating some Aid agencies having
to pause their work what is happening on
the ground well in Turkey there is good
organization uh and uh Britain sent
immediately 77 search and rescue experts
with the top-notch equipment to help
they arrived pretty rapidly they have
four sniffer dogs with them and they
have a team of emergency medical
operatives to assess what else can be
done on the ground in conjunction with
the Turkish authorities so so as far as
turkey is concerned
um we are I think doing what is required
two flights took off last night to help
one from RAF Bryce Norton in Britain one
from our stores in Dubai taking tents
and blankets into turkey and much of
that is of course is Bound for Syria it
is in Syria that the International
Community is far more stretched we were
able to get through the one Crossing
that is open for the UN but that
Crossing two was badly damaged in the
earthquake and because of the Russian
veto the U.N cannot use the other three
Crossings out of turkey into Syria so so
it is it is in in Syria that the real uh
problems lie we were able to react
faster because the white helmets which
were the Civil Defense group during the
war they are the responders the First
Responders in Syria and they were able
to uh get get in there and try and help
people out from under the rubble rescue
people and we supported them immediately
with uh some money some more money 24
hours later and that will help them put
fuel in their cars rent and hire
equipment uh provide for blankets and
local stores and help the people there
who as I say because there's no
infrastructure and it's ungoverned space
are in very deep Jeopardy and of course
the temperature last night was minus
five degrees in the region I mean you
can't imagine can you with the
infrastructure as you say just crumbling
and temperatures at that level and you
talk about the situation in Syria being
much more complicated obviously you know
Assad is a dictator he's murdered his
own people we obviously don't have a
diplomatic relationship with him does
that make it more difficult well well it
doesn't in these circumstances because
we negotiate with the Syrian authorities
through the United Nations and as I said
Martin Griffiths is on the ground there
he's he's a Brit he's the senior British
official at the United Nations and he's
in charge of the United Nations relief
effort and having him there as a voice
for the International Community makes
our position with the Syrian government
extremely strong so the difficulty is
because the devastation in the country
already because of the years of Civil
War and I have to note that you know the
latest figures show that our AIDS ending
in Syria halved and we spent 181 million
in 2020 and 91 million in 2021 was that
the right thing to do well you know if
you look at the amount of money that
Britain has spent supporting the the
victims of the war the syrians who've
had to move and actually half of Syria
was on the move both to the four
countries around Syria but also
internally displaced and of course a
million of them across into Europe now
throughout that time Britain supported
the Syrian
um displaced people the Syrian refugees
we're still supporting them but the
money's gone down we did we did more for
those refugees and the whole of the rest
of the European Union put together in
terms of support and financial uh
support for the rescue uh efforts
um but but as far as Syria is concerned
it's not really about money we have
provided the funds that were needed for
the white helmets the although the
budget as you as you imply is under
considerable stress when it comes to
humanitarian work we have some
flexibility the point is my point is
that the situation is worse in Syria not
just because of the earthquake but
because of the infrastructure the
hospitals already creaking the country
devastated because of years of war at a
time when we have cut halves the amount
of Aid we're spending yes as I said the
budget is is is under very considerable
stress but we are still spending a great
deal of money there not far short of 200
million pounds so we're doing what we
can and we are having a big effect on
the ground and it is partly because of
the work we do through International
ngos as well as through the United
Nations that we know what's happening on
the ground there and we are therefore
able to ensure that British help really
gets through to those who need it I want
to talk a little bit about the aid
budget as well I know that you over your
career have been someone who's been a
big proponent about the importance of
international Aid of course we should
see that cups our Aid budget from 0.7 of
GDP to 0.5 back in 21. that was supposed
to last for three years so will it go
back up to 0.7 next year
well it will go back up to 0.7 when the
two fiscal tests that were set down by
Rishi and confirmed by parliament are
met I can't tell you precisely when that
will be because it's not clear how
quickly the economy is going to recover
the economy has suffered significantly
from Putin's illegal war in Ukraine and
also of course from the aftermath of
covid so I can't give you an answer to
that but what I can tell you is that my
job is to try and make sure that we have
multipliers which augment the money that
we can use and we are doing that as fast
as we possibly can and also that we made
our case to the treasury one of the
problems for the budget is that we meet
the cost of the first year of Ukrainian
refugees who have sought sanctuary in
Britain that's perfectly proper it's
part of the use that of the aid budget
as as defined but we made our case to
the treasury and the treasury did manage
to find an extra two and a half billion
pounds for of taxpayers money so we're
we're spending it about 0.55 now but we
will get back to 0.7 as soon as the
fiscal tests are met and the economic
circumstances allow you obviously can't
tell us when that will be I just want to
have a look at what you said at the time
the aid budget was cut you said this you
said
no one should be any any doubt about the
damage these huge humanitarian Cuts have
done to the world's poorest and to the
reputation and effectiveness of British
leadership that's what you said in
October 2021 what I mean what happened
to that Andrew Mitchell that Andrew
Mitchell is now doing his very best to
ensure that we mitigate the huge
humanitarian Cuts in the way that I
describe by finding these multipliers
for example some people might say that
you've sold out on your principles or
any government job let me explain why I
don't think that's true so we're using
these multipliers to find extra money an
example would be when I was in the Horn
of Africa where we have just staved off
a famine this year uh last year
um we were able to do some co-financing
with other countries which increased the
amount of money that was brought to bear
on that crisis so I'm looking at ways of
mitigating the humanitarian effects and
in terms of the reputation and
effectiveness of British leadership we
are on the case I'm hoping to make sure
that the merger with the foreign office
of diffid works better and the foreign
secretary and I are agreed on a number
of measures which I hope will be
announced in the integrated review which
will help address that very point no I
can't help but think you know whether it
ever crosses your mind that they've
given you this job in government because
you'll be less trouble for them as a
government Minister than on the back
benches you know if you were on the back
benches right now I kind of think that
you'd be on the airwaves saying look
this is just why we need to restore the
aid budget that says why we need to help
the poorest countries in the world and
yes the economic situation is difficult
but that's exactly why we should be
spending more in Aid because of course
the people who suffer when Global
inflation is the highest are the very
poorest well in terms of what I would be
saying I am obviously governed by
Collective responsibility and uh but
Collective responsibility is not
retrospective and I'm doing my very best
to make the system work and you know if
you're a politician you always have to
decide whether or not you are better off
on the outside of the tent trying to do
what you can by shouting from the
sidelines or whether it is better to get
inside and try and improve the situation
and I'm doing the latter there's a lot
of Focus right now on whether the
ministry of Defense budget should
increase partly of course because the
war in Ukraine in the Sunday Times today
the they say the defense secretary is
demanding an extra 10 billion pounds
over the next two years are you lobbying
in a similar way for the aid budget
well as I say the fiscal tests will need
to be met for us to go back to 0.7 but
by finding other ways of increasing the
funding we are doing every thing we can
to compensate for that diminution and
you may rest assured I make the case for
the development Budget on every occasion
as far as far as the defense budget is
concerned
um Jeremy Hunt made significant
announcements during the Autumn
statement we are I think one of the only
uh uh NATO countries spending two
percent of our gni on defense that is
absolutely necessary the war in Ukraine
has shown what a dangerous world we live
in and I think the government has
stepped up by producing this extra money
and we are the leading NATO country in
Europe and I think we will see in the
integrated review refresh which is
likely to be announced in March that
Britain is absolutely focused both on
stopping the Russian aggression and
supporting the ukrainians and making
sure that our defense is fit for purpose
now in other news today the U.S has shot
down an unidentified cylindrical object
over Canada now we don't have more
details about what that is but of course
it comes off the back of the so-called
Chinese spy balloon that was shot down
over the US How concerned should we be
about the role of China
well I think we need to get to the
bottom of this uh transparency is most
important we need to find out exactly
what's been going on what these objects
in the air are doing what their purpose
is and then we will be able to reach a
judgment I mean I think it's quite clear
that both Canada and the United States
have met their obligations to their
citizens and intercepting them and
destroying them and once we've seen what
was actually involved in the technology
we'll be able to make a judgment about
that of course some of your colleagues
on conservative benches have some real
concerns about China and about the
influence Alicia Cairns for example on
this program last week the chair of the
Foreign Affairs elect committee told me
that I should delete tiktok for my phone
because of Chinese capability do you
think she's got a point
well I don't know I'm afraid I'm a bit
of an analog politician in a digital age
but uh I think it's easier I think I
think that what Alicia says about uh
China is extremely important she chairs
the Foreign Affairs select committee and
many of my colleagues and friends like
Ian Duncan Smith former leader of the
party have been very clear about this
what I would say from the point of view
of the foreign office and the government
is we do have to have a relationship
with China we can't just cut it all off
because otherwise if we don't talk to
them we won't make any progress at all
and we want to try and make the Chinese
government more receptive to and
involved in the International System and
bring them in it's a very long-term
project but we can't just cut off all
relations with China but we have to
stand up for our values both here and
abroad against many of the things that
China does of which we do not approve we
have been sending the maid as well 50
million pounds in 2021 should we be
doing that well I was very surprised to
see this because in 2010 the first thing
I did when the Coalition arrived in
government was to stop all Aid for China
there may be a case occasionally for
some joint technical assistance to be
deployed but we shouldn't be giving Aid
to China and we're looking to make sure
that that Aid is better spent oh really
so you think that actually going forward
that 50 million pounds is not going to
happen again well I think there will
have to be a very strong case indeed and
it would have to be an open and public
case if we'd spend Aid money in China it
could be better spent in other countries
well that is that is my starting point
yes and then just finally and we're
going to be talking to your colleague
John Redwood on the program a little uh
later on now we know of course at you
know Liz truss Ally who would like to
see tax cuts on the budget next month do
you think now's the right time to cut
taxes Well we'd all like to see uh tax
cuts uh we're a tax cutting party and
I've served with John in the House of
Commons on and off since 1987 when we
were both first elected he makes a very
strong point about the importance of tax
cuts for the economy but you know in the
end if we make tax cuts which are not
properly funded it's merely it's
borrowing and it's taxation deferred for
the the Next Generation and you know
many of us are very concerned about
intergenerational unfairness in Britain
the position of our children and indeed
our grandchildren so so I think tax cuts
are very important but they've got to be
done at the right time and I think that
the philosophy and argument that the
chancellor of the exchequer has set out
is absolutely right we will get them
when we can but I think at the moment
it's extremely difficult to justify them
I guess the argument for those on the
John Redwood side is that actually tax
cuts sort of pay for themselves because
they boost growth investment in the UK
do you think there's the point there
well there is a bit of that but I think
the much more important point is that
the chance of the ex-jacker has to take
a judgment about when is the right time
to do it and when we can afford it and
he set out the arguments very clearly in
the Autumn statement that now is not the
time to do that okay thank you very much
indeed thank you